good morning john it's been a time it's
been a week
it's been a month it's been a year the
perseverance rover is on the surface of
mars the project for awesome was amazing
and john it is time for me to do my
first ever inaugural meme review when i
have asked nerdfighteria if it's okay
for this video to be long and they said
yes because it has to be we must do the
memes
justice now most of you are thinking
right now oh that's nice hank's got a
picture of the perseverance rover's
first image of mars
behind him close the beans didn't stop
coming that's right beanie soon ferbs
you're famous
they love you everybody loves you i'm
aware that not everybody loves beanies
sanford
we don't have to let them know that
though i have to apologize for one thing
is that which is that i downloaded all
these throughout the project for awesome
and so i
didn't like maintain any context i have
no idea who made any of these things
so up front let me say thank you to
everyone who made these like these
aren't things that just appeared out of
the ether
people worked hard to make this stuff
sometimes
more hard than other times some people
worked hours on things
some less than that john on my desktop i
got a folder called beanbee
and it contains four other folders bean
memes
just beans normal memes and art so we're
gonna go through a selection of each one
of those let's start with just
normal memes this was the one that
started out the project for awesome for
me it's sue from glee and the thing that
i like about this so much is it could
have been i am going to donate to a
product that is so awesome that's
the choice i would make but this choice
is so much better it's me
i am once again asking for your
financial support we're starting with
project for awesome specific memes here
there shouldn't be too many beans here
uh well here's one dang it that didn't
take long i was having a hard time
saying beanie sand verbs for a long time
uh so i've ended up with a lot of cards
this is a good one
for awesome perks they take time to make
and uh and i want to be careful
which i have not been in the past that i
do not end up in a situation where i'm
over promising
on my ability so this pink blob is just
all the other stuff that i have to do i
love that's what i look like
that is an accurate picture of my face
right there
a spray-painted anglerfish is something
that can actually be so personal my
strange addiction i'm constantly
donating
yeah good kitties i love the memes that
are encouraging donations and there's
plenty of them
this is another one when the matching
fun hits a large donation the size of a
small donation is completely blocking
each
it's the boulder it's the boulder meme
you guys brain scrambled egg
wallet p4a it's a dangerous day to get
paid um
was that was the tagline of like the
project for awesome 2014 or something
it's true but we're not denying it it's
harder to make good
sound financial decisions during the
project for awesome give directly to p4i
do not pass go please donate 200 thank
you to everybody who followed their
monopoly card look the project for
awesome does make me feel better about
the future
and humanity more money irresponsibility
yeah oh this one's good the project for
awesome digital bundle it's got all the
infinity stones in it you can't help
yourself i mean it is
okay it is watch the p4a and you buy
your perk early and donate to charity
but you keep watching the live stream
but more
cool perks come out so you donate again
there is no separating ourselves from
the universe
and beanie sand verbs look it's not like
we created these personas
for a youtube channel that's just how he
is and this is just how i am oh
flula started to call me billy hank
because my first name is william
uh and then somebody made this i love it
i love how as i've gotten older in this
photograph my head really sank
like down to my sternum i'm sure that
post malone gets compared to every
person who writes
on their face and i'm sure that that's
not fun for post malone
but it's fun for me thank god catherine
came out i thought i was gonna write
names on my own
face in a mirrored image
no i can't i can't cut a single hair off
my head in the mirror
i can barely shave moving on to just
bean memes
all of these are bean memes it's nearly
as many as all of the other memes put
together this one sparks joy glenn and
dale of the glen they were our mascots
last year
our mascot this year this one does not
spark joy look
look he can hear you oh
i have nothing to say he is so big
i guess i had that to say i just had
that one thing to say i love it and so
does harry
harry loves it too beanie sanfurbs is
better than dave the fish
changed my mind and it's beanie sanford
sitting at the table so you're not gonna
be able to as soon as somebody posted a
traced out picture of beanie
sanfurbs it all was lost more
beanie sand as me turning my back on
dave the fish
a previous project for awesome mascot to
focus solely on beanies and verbs
and i didn't even have dave the fish
this year junk it's me now stunk
is not just adam levine for men mixed
with adam levine for women changed my
mind
it's got the dftba mugs that's so good
it's not i don't know where everybody
got this idea and then the comeback
beanie sanfurb's coming back this one
sparks joy this one does not spark joy
take that
glen of the glenn now it's just beanie
sanfurb's asking for your financial
support look
we were all asking for your financial
support it's the project for awesome i
really like this one
thank you for changing project for
awesome i'm literally a deeply
disturbing furby made out of beans
people
again hating on beanies and verbs it
goes both ways
for example i don't want to see a normal
furby no
do i want to see a bean furby yes drake
does
mini sanford isn't a bad p4a mascot i'm
giving a presentation
you guys are just bean
no and also yes i like this one i don't
know
what they did but they made it look like
this was almost part of a comic i don't
maybe that just is a picture of their
computer screen it isn't because that's
the same picture and that doesn't have
that artifact they made it look like it
was part of a newspaper
my reflection's staring back at me from
this from the black screen when project
for awesome men's
i that face that you're making when the
when it fades to black and you can see
yourself
beanies and ferbs this is 100 true oh my
god
i hate hate that kind of color corrected
to his skin tone
that wasn't necessary you didn't have to
do that
[Laughter]
oops all beans that was kind of the
tagline of the project for awesome this
year and i love that they surrounded
where the
cereal was with beans they outlined it
and put some beans in
got beanies and verbs is the stonk sky
but it's beans and that does it for our
bean memes now we must move on to a
category that is labeled just beans
so this isn't even memes show the
scishow logo it's hosted by beanie
sanford
beans for awesome project and it's got
beans beanie styles
fashion forward this is a picture from
me from like
i don't know fifth grade maybe with
beanie sanford's face
this is a choice that someone made here
we have not the only beanie sanford's
valentine i've seen
this is perseverance rover with beanie
stand firms aboard
thank goodness someone during the
project we weren't even done yet had
knitted a beanie sanfurbs or crocheted
or whatever that is art that should be
in the art folder
someone has made my child into a large
beanie sanfurbs
more art wrong folder chugger of beans
destroyer of worlds
that's me god those were hot beans the
effort like how did you make
the wanda vision logo so perfectly
where did you find the font and i'm
there it's me and i've got the
vision thingy in my head oh
god inspiration it's inspired it carries
so much emotion
the mustache the the stuff on the head
the eyes the down cast eyes and this
was one of the very first things i saw
it was beanie sanford's hatching out of
the chicago beans
it's john lima bean hank bean and it's
got some musical notes
and i don't know why god that is some
high quality
turning bernie sanders into beanie
sanford during the project this kind of
messed me up for a little bit i could i
i had to like host a charity live stream
but i was so preoccupied with the long
long long beanie sanfords with all of
the legs you guys believe i interviewed
barack obama and also
that i didn't cut my hair beforehand
they told me to show up how i would
normally dress and then i got there and
they were like we're gonna need to take
you to a store
i should have given him some beans
travis macaroni was on the stream while
this happened
was he offended a little bit and then
this which turned into a project for
awesome perk
it's a laser etched and laser-cut beanie
sanford's coaster which means we have
only one
category left it's the category called
art this is just gross ice cream
alive living gross ice cream with beans
raining down you can't forget that they
took the time
to have a background of bean rain this
is choppa's
amazing beanie sanfurbs cake i didn't
get to see like the moment where you the
knife goes through the cake
which i kind of wish i i had gotten that
opportunity and also i love i'd love to
have a bite
but i also didn't get that opportunity
does it taste like baked beans
i know that there are bean cakes i've
had them before they're not usually in
australia but who knows
god it's so shiny oh man if there's
anything
like slimier than beanie sanford it's
cake bean
wow thank you choppa lollipop the skunk
after doing finger painting oh god it's
too cute it doesn't belong here it
doesn't belong with all these cursed
images this is just good
i like that you know you didn't go all
in on this shiny beanie santa verbs
drawn with circles like john's been
doing those circle drawings it's a
little bit touching
which it shouldn't be this one is just
uh leaning a bit more into the shiny
looking kind of like uh an arrangement
of dried beans which makes it
uh much more pleasing to the eye though
the flesh colored background
doesn't really spark joy i my heart when
i saw this one look at this art
look at this freaking butt fartman hank
green
dr seuss carrying green eggs and a ham
on its finger
how is this possible i do not like that
sand for bean i do not like it
it is obscene i do not like it in the
dark i do not like it in my heart
i do not like it on the stream its
presence cannot be unseen
i do not like it in the night bean
sanford's gives me a fright
it hurts my brain it hurts my eyes but
worst of all
i do despise that beanie ferv this is
absurd this could be said with the curse
word but then that curse word would be
blurred i think this is a british accent
i'll say it loud
i'll say it clea that sand ferbs gives
me nerdfighteria
which is a flula joke so threw in a
fluna joke on top of all of it
i died i almost missed this one
it's a it's a pelican made out of shiny
beans
just a beanie saucy pelican it's so
good it's so good i don't want to say
it's not good
oh my god everything about it is so good
i don't like it i love pelicans and i
love beans and i love the project for
awesome like look at this
bean covered project for awesome heart
oh my god it's so good
i but i can't i can't like it it's too
cursed
this is a thing that i dislike and like
at this like at the same intensity and
the intensity of both is very high
i'm new to that emotion that's a new one
for me i'm 40 years old that doesn't
happen often oh
but this one i just love all the
different paper
spiral circles they're made into shapes
of beans
the gradients are perfect it's much more
pleasing
to look at than actual beanie sanfurbs
i mean this blew me away when i saw it
luxembourg
the superhero of the project for awesome
not enough box man was happening
love it so much this is beanie sanford's
cross stitch really
very good i just love being a part of
this
with people it just seems like such an
extraordinary opportunity that like
we didn't know we were getting ourselves
into and then the results are these just
wonderful moments
chunky milk make pain go away uh i don't
know how to explain that one and then
our last piece of art is this
absolutely gorgeous i don't know
what to call this kind of art but it's
got the little 20 21 tag
and his eyes are perfect there's a lot
of time and energy and effort went into
this
cursed bean boy i don't want to
overstate this but it's these
contributions to
to community that make me really feel
like
i'm a part of something and that's a
really valuable thing
feeling like you're a part of a
community feeling like you're a part of
change in the world and the project for
awesome
makes a really big change it makes a
change in my heart
it makes impact in the real world we're
going to be able to distribute
a ton of money to a ton of different
charities it's going to have a lot of
real world
impact but it also i think has real
world impact on the people who
participate whether they are
stitching weird bean furbies donating
hanging out in the project for awesome
chat making memes
creating ideas just singing digitally we
are here because we're here because
we're here because we're here
all that is super valuable and i think
it can also be kind of hard
to find these days so thank you so much
for everyone for being a part of this
community whether you are around for the
project for awesome or not thank you to
everybody who made stuff who volunteered
who was on the live stream thanks to all
the mods
and the core team people who did designs
who are organizing who's scheduled it
was
it's a ton of work to make this thing
come together but it's value and we all
come together to create it is far
beyond what all of us together put in
like we all put in work but the value
that comes out is just way
bigger than the work put in and what
else can we ask for
as people so thank you to everybody who
was part of it and john
i'll see you on tuesday